Mithridates says should I hide my anti
femme anti feminism I presume as I study
University to become a nurse well look
you shouldn't make unnecessary enemies
and you probably shouldn't mouth your
opinion more than necessary but I think
you risk damaging your soul under
certain circumstances when you don't say
what you think so I wouldn't hide it
because I think it's dangerous to hide
it and you also won't find out find the
other people that you listen to but I
would say be prudent
you know don't falsify your opinions
when you're writing that's a big mistake
don't falsify your opinions when you're
speaking you can always choose not to
speak you know but if you feel that you
would be doing damage to your integrity
then you have to say what you have to
say do it carefully and and prepare for
the consequences you know probably
prepare beforehand I would say so
I think the hiding is a bad idea like I
said but don't make unnecessary enemies
you know because there's just no utility
in that how important do you believe the
American right is the American right to
bear arms and maintain militias is it
equivalent to the right to free speech
well I don't think anything is
or the responsibility for free speech
how important do I believe that that
right is Jesus that's a tough question
you know my dad's a hunter he has to
under grateful something like that
they're all single shots because he
believes a naming carefully the culture
I come from which is north Western
Canada is a rural culture a hunting
culture people take their gun seriously
there and it is definitely part of their
lifestyle maybe my dad hunted his whole
life and we ate wild meat
almost
all the time I was growing up I think
that the right to bear arms is one of
the markers of a free society I don't
think it's reasonable that only the
police and the army should be allowed to
be dangerous
having said that well I think I'll just
leave it at that I mean I feel obligated
in some sense to go farther especially
with regards to what happened in Las
Vegas but it seems to me that most of
what happens after these mass shootings
is that the event gets absolutely
politicized and people take their
standard positions and there's no moving
either side and that's too bad but
I think that it's unfortunate to use an
event like the Las Vegas event or the
Columbine shootings to make political
capital and I think that's usually what
happens and so I'm not going to do that
I think it's an important right I
believe that the individual should be
allowed or even encouraged to be
dangerous but controlled you know so
along with that right is a
responsibility and and I guess maybe
from the NRA there should be more
discussion of responsibility is that
possible that seems to me to be
reasonable so